Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a German comedy film
called “Suck Me Shakespeer.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Zeki Müller is a felon serving prison time for
robbing a bank. He attends an academic class in
prison where the inmates are provided different
levels of education. On evaluating Zeki’s
knowledge, the teacher discovers that he is dumber
than a middle schooler. She thinks he should be
locked away from society because of his lack of
general knowledge. But against her wish, Zeki is
being released that day. He walks out of prison
with a trashy phone and a few pennies to start
a new life. But he is not worried at all.
It turns out that he had stolen a million euros
right before going to prison. His friend Zeynep
takes him to the place where she has buried the
money and gives him the coordinates of the exact
spot. To Zeki’s surprise, a school’s gymnasium has
been built over his money. He is distressed
but determined to get the money back.
In the following scene, a gangster
bangs Zeki’s dead onto a table,
asking for two thousand euros worth of loan
that he had borrowed before imprisonment.
Zeki promises to get the money back in a few
weeks and in turn asks for accommodation. The
gangster owns a strip club and allows him to
crash in one of the display rooms. That night,
Zeki decides to get a job as a
janitor in the school. That way,
he can gain access to the gymnasium and
can build a tunnel up to his money.
The following day, he goes to the school for an
interview and bumps into a teacher named Lisi.
She has a cheerful personality, a trait that her
students either love or hate. Zeki goes to the
principal’s office and sees a bunch of people
waiting for a job interview. Although they
are overly dressed for a janitor, Zeki doesn’t
think much of it. To get rid of the competition,
he breaks the fire alarm, making everyone
run away. When the principal comes outside,
he tells her a student broke it accidentally.
Zeki soon finds out that the principal thinks
he is there to apply for the job of a substitute
teacher. He tries explaining otherwise but she
doesn’t give him a chance. When Zeki finds out
that the teachers get a spare key to the gym
and a salary of two thousand euros,
he cannot let the opportunity go.
Now, the only problem is his academic
qualifications that he needs to hand in
the next day. Outside the school, Lisi is trying
to stop a student who is smoking. Zeki helps her
and asks her for a favor. He pretends to
be interested in sharing the syllabus but
in reality, wants to steal her academic
certification to use it as his own.
Later that day, they meet at her house and share
an awkward conversation. When she is distracted,
Zeki drugs her cup of tea that makes her pass
out. Taking the opportunity, he searches the
entire house for her academic certification and
tries to print it. But just when he is in a hurry,
the printer refuses to work. So instead, Zeki
transfers the file to a flash drive. Lisi’s
friend Caro arrives home and is about to catch him
in the act. Zeki makes it seem like he and Lisi
are in bed together and covers up his plan.
The following morning, they bump into each other
at school but Zeki doesn’t acknowledge what
happened yesterday. Lisi is bothered because
to her, they had gotten a bit too
close than they should have.
Zeki walks into the teacher’s room right before
a teacher jumps off the window. She had been so
troubled by the students of her class that
she decided to end her own life. Thankfully,
she survives the fall and is taken to the
hospital. But now, in her place, Lisi is
assigned to class 10 B. The students of the class
are known as the devils in disguise. They play
seemingly harmless pranks on the teachers and make
their life a living hell. Suffice to say that Lisi
is not too thrilled about the assignment.
In his first class, Zeki orders the students to
bring a VCD of their favorite movie every day for
them to watch in his class. The one who chooses
the best movie will get better grades. Zeki seems
to be enjoying teaching but the same cannot be
said for Lisi. The students laugh at every word
she says and do not cooperate. When she picks
up chalk, a slimy substance sticks it to her
fingers. Then, as she tries to wash it off, the
faucet breaks. She realizes the student had set
up the prank and dries herself off with a towel,
only to find out that it has been smothered with
a black substance. Humiliated, she tries to leave
but the door handle has dog feces stuck to it.
After being utterly defeated by the monsters,
she requests the principal to let her
share the responsibility with someone.
However, the principal asks her to leave if she
cannot handle the pressure of being a teacher.
That night, Zeki goes to the school’s gym to start
digging for his money. Meanwhile, at Lisi’s home,
her friend Caro fixes the printer that prints out
Lisi’s academic results. On looking up the details
of the print, they figure out that it was done
when Zeki was in the house and Lisi was passed
out. Lisi suspects him of using her diploma to get
the job. She drives to the and checks his files in
the principal’s office. On matching the results,
she realizes that her suspicion is true. Minutes
later, she bumps into Zeki and calls him out for
using her diploma. He asks her to name her price
but Lisi doesn’t want any money, all she wants
is to get rid of her duty as 10 B’s teacher.
The next day, they request the principal to swap
their duties. Zeki steps into the classroom and
comes across a male genital drawn on the board.
He tries to fetch something from the cupboard
but accidentally sets his hands on mouse traps. As
he retreats, a slimy black substance drops on him,
and the students burst out laughing.
Still, he tries continuing the class
but is stuck to the chair in the process. The
following day, Zeki arrives prepared with a
paintball gun. Some students are outside skipping
classes and refusing to come even when asked. He
hits them with the gun and gathers them all in the
class. He only wants them to stay quiet for his
period and doesn’t care if they study or not.
When Lisi arrives to ask for chalk, she sees a
student crying. She tells Zeki about it, to which
he asks the student to cry silently. Lisi realizes
that he isn’t teaching them anything and is
getting paid for just sitting there. That night,
Zeki is kicked out of the strip club because of
accommodation difficulties. With nowhere to go,
he ends up at Lisi’s home. Lisi and Caro
mistake him for an intruder and beat him
up before realizing who he actually is. He
stays the night at the house with Lisi, Caro,
and Lisi’s younger sister Laura. The next morning,
Zeki begs Lisi to let him stay at their house for
two weeks. Initially, she doesn’t want a fraud
like him around them but then, she gets an idea.
She agrees to let him stay but only if he actually
teaches 10 B and not just hangs around with them.
Desperate for a place, Zeki accepts the offer.
To help him teach, she gives him the reading
material and the syllabus. Caro also
advises him to control the class’s leaders;
Daniel and Chantel. If the leaders respect
him, the others will automatically follow.
Zeki reads the details about the leaders
and finds out they are micro criminals.
Later that day, Lisi and Zeki go to the strip club
to get dinner. Lisi tells him that Daniel of class
10 B wants to be a drug dealer in the future,
which is the primary reason why he is uninterested
in studying. With this information, Zeki might be
able to help the students, even though he is not
in the least interested in doing so. That night
while digging through the gym, he finds a time
capsule buried several years ago. On checking,
he discovers Lisi’s picture and a note inside. He
laughs at her note where she wishes she weren’t so
fat. Eventually, he falls asleep on his desk.
In the morning, the students take advantage of
his unconsciousness and give him a makeover.
Lisi helps him in the toilet because he
feels sick. The care she shows for him
is unlike anything Zeki has ever experienced.
He slowly but surely starts falling for her.
The following day, Zeki takes class 10 B
to an educational tour to a dealer’s house.
Daniel witnesses what the life of an actual
criminal looks like and decides to take a
different career path. Zeki advises the students
to join Lisi’s theater class if they do not want
to end up like the dealer. They do as told and
audition for a Romeo and Juliet play. Daniel
auditions for the role of Romeo and does great.
However, Zeki thinks the drama is too boring. He
and the students collectively re-write the play
and make a modern and entertaining version.
A few more weeks go by in a similar fashion.
Zeki continues digging the tunnel through the
gymnasium. He and Lisi get along well and
the students have started to study instead
of creating trouble all the time. One day,
the teacher’s ratings given by the students
are released on the internet. Lisi is disappointed
because she doesn’t get selected for any category.
To most of the teachers, it is just a silly game
but since Lisi wants her students to like her,
she feels extremely down.
To make her feel better, Zeki takes her
and the students to a station where they vandalize
a train. The students see the fun side of Lisi
for the first time and start to respect her. They
have to run away after almost being caught by the
police but Lisi enjoys the night nonetheless. The
next day, the students greet her in the hallway
and politely agree to do everything she says.
Then, they go on a field trip to a farm for a
project. The children are playing around when they
accidentally hit her with a sex hormone that makes
her high. At the end of the day, Zeki has to carry
her home and calm her hormones down. Her younger
sister Laura is worried because the people from
child services are going to be there any minute.
If they see Lisi in such a condition, they might
reconsider letting Laura live with her. When Lisi
wakes up a while later, she sees Zeki and Laura
talking to the person from child services. Zeki
pretends to be her caring boyfriend and kisses her
as an act. After the official leaves, Lisi asks
him what he wants in turn for the favor. To her
surprise, he replies that he did it for Laura.
That evening, Zeki finally finds the money
that he had been looking for. He goes through
a rollercoaster of emotions and starts crying
tears of happiness. He then goes to the strip club
and pays off his debts. When asked where he
wants to go now, Zeki claims he has started
to like his new life. On the day of the modern
Romeo and Juliet play, everyone is nervous. At
the end of the day, the play is a hit and gets
second place in the competition. The students
are overjoyed because this is the first thing
they did as a group that was successful.
The following day at gym class, a student performs
a high jump and accidentally reveals the tunnel
under the gymnasium. When Lisi goes down to check,
she overhears Zeki on the other side talking to
someone on the phone. He reveals everything about
his true intentions of coming to school. Lisi
feels betrayed and used by him. She also learns
about his past as a criminal and threatens to
call the police if he does not leave his job and
her home immediately. With no way to convince
her otherwise, Zeki agrees to go away. The next
day is the big test that the students have been
preparing for a long time. Before it starts, they
bring out different pictures and stare at them.
On being asked they reveal that Zeki had advised
them to bring a picture of what they love the most
to keep them motivated. A student informs Lisi
that Zeki's motivation photo is in his drawer.
Curious, she checks it and finds a picture of
herself that he had found in the time capsule.
Just then, Zeynep arrives with a letter that
Zeki left for Lisi. The letter says that he is
sorry for breaking her trust. He also explains
that he had decided to start a new life as a
teacher even after getting the money.
Zeynep adds that Zeki is on his way to rob
a bank with a bad influence. If Lisi doesn’t
stop him, he might enter the crime world again.
Lisi immediately tries calling him but the call
goes straight to voicemail. She gets an idea to
use a science project to communicate with him.
With the help of the students, the plan works
but Zeki's crime partner breaks the project. At
last, Zeki realizes he wants to continue living
his life as a teacher and ditches the plan.
Following that, he goes home with a gift for Lisi
and asks her to be his prom date. She opens the
box and finds a beautiful dress inside. They meet
at the end of the stairs and kiss. At school, the
principal cries while checking 10 B’s test papers.
The progress they have shown is exemplary and all
credit goes to Zeki. She wants him to stay as a
permanent teacher but Zeki comes clean and tells
her he isn’t qualified. The principal doesn’t seem
to care. She forges a high school diploma for him
and allows him to stay. At last, the couple joins
everyone at the prom and enjoys it.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.